MALE SPEAKER: So, Happy
Earth Day, everyone.
We're very pleased to host
today one of the crusaders
for conservation,
Dr. Laurie Marker.
She's the founder and
executive director
of the Cheetah
Conservation Fund.
And she brings over
30 years of experience
to the race to save the cheetah.
Dr. Marker has implemented a
variety of conservation efforts
in Namibia, ranging from
livestock-guarding dog programs
to bush block to save the prey.
Dr. Marker is also going to talk
a little bit about her latest
book which was published
just yesterday,
"A Future for Cheetahs."
It's a large format book,
chronicling cheetahs
in the wild and it features
photography by Suzi Eszterhas.
And so, we'll have some
time for Q&A at the end.
But without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming Laurie to Google.
Thank you.
LAURIE MARKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, it's great to be here.
And Earth Day, especially.
This is like the 44th
year of Earth Day.
Anyone remember the first one?
Yeah, I know.
I do, too.
But that's good.
I was, then, also on a
Google Hangout today,
which was kind of neat,
talking about kind
of the two polar
opposites-- the polar bears
and the cheetah,
both iconic species.
And both-- most
people don't realize
how climate change is affecting
animals like the cheetah.
But we are talking about
climate change as well.
And for cheetahs, it's all about
living in harmony with them
in Africa.
So we have to figure out
how to live and flourish
with cheetahs.
Everyone knows that the cheetah
is the fastest land animal.
And we do have a
cheetah that you're
going to meet here
a little bit later.
But just to talk about it.
You'll see it as
it's walking and I
want you to just think a bit
about how special they are.
But they're aerodynamic
and built for speed.
Today, the world's about speed.
However, there's nothing
that can equal a cheetah.
And it's on the earth.
There are only about
10,000 of them left.
So they are very special.
But they're the most specialized
of all the 37 species of cats.
So we'll talk more
about the cheetah
when it comes out
a little bit later.
But we'll talk a little
bit about, you know,
being an icon of speed.
Because they're so beautiful.
And if we lose them,
the pronghorned antelope
becomes the next
fastest land animal.
Although it's
beautiful as well, it's
got not quite the same iconic
vision as that of the cheetah.
Fast like a pronghorn.
Well, the pronghorn is fast
because the cheetah actually
used to live in North America.
And predators and prey play a
very key role living together.
And we always talk
about cheetahs
as being a very important
part of ecosystems.
Ecosystems keep us all alive.
And predators are something
that we think, around the world,
should actually go away.
And most of our predators are
vulnerable to extinction today
because of the way we view them.
However, when we
have top predators,
we have a healthier ecosystem
with more biodiversities.
And cheetahs play
a very key role
in this in the
grassland ecosystems.
With only about 10,000 cheetahs
remaining in the world,
what's happened to them?
We've lost 90% of our cheetahs
in the last 100 years.
The area on this map
here that is darker brown
is the area where
cheetahs are found today.
So they're living in very
small numbers, fragmented
through a continent
that is huge.
In the last 50 years, we've
lost about 16 countries
where cheetahs are living.
The cheetah was found in India
and became extinct in the '50s,
in the Middle East in the '70s.
The last of the Asian
cheetahs is found in Iran
where there are only
about 60 cheetahs.
Cheetahs are an animal
that don't do well
in protected game reserves.
So although we think of Africa
as being a very large continent
with lots of wildlife,
they don't do well
because lions and hyenas steal
their food, kill their young,
and push them out of
these systems that
are not very large.
But that's where they are the
kings of the game reserves.
And so, cheetahs get
pushed out, they're
in conflict with
humans and livestock.
And throughout Africa,
we've got human populations
that are growing.
And most people who are
living in sub-Saharan Africa
have lots and lots of livestock.
And the poor, rural
livestock farmers
often don't take very good
care of their animals.
And if a cheetah
or other predators
catch one of the livestock,
then they're oftentimes killed.
So that's the issues that
we're actually facing.
So these pictures here show a
bit about what that looks like.
Up in the very top on your
right is actually cubs.
And we've got a very
bad illegal trade
going on today in Northern
Africa going into the Middle
East for the pet trade.
I live in Namibia.
Namibia is a democratic country.
It's about 2 and 1/2 times
the size of California.
Very, very arid where we're
very prone to drought cycles.
And with this, it's now the
last large habitat for cheetahs.
We have about 3,000 to 4,000 of
the remaining 10,000 cheetahs.
We've doubled that
population in the 25 years
that I've set up the
Cheetah Conservation Fund.
And our vision is really to see
a world in which cheetahs live
in harmony and
flourish in coexistence
with people and the environment.
And that's, I think,
a big thing today
is that we have forgotten
how to co-exist.
And the cheetah
doesn't live inside
of a square box
of a game reserve.
It's made me think for about 40
years about how to save them.
And that's outside square boxes.
And I've had to look at
world-changing things.
And it's interesting,
how does one actually
go about changing the world?
Google had changed the world.
The cheetah is changing
the world as well.
Now over a 40 year
period of time,
I thought, well, I know
a lot about cheetahs.
And I've studied them.
I know more about
them then probably
most anybody knows about
any living species.
And yet, with this,
just knowing about them
is not going to save them.
So I set out about 25
years ago and moved
to Namibia, a country
I'd traveled to a lot,
to try to find out why
people were killing cheetahs.
When I got to
Namibia, farmers were
killing about 1,000
cheetahs a year.
It was indiscriminate.
They saw a cheetah, it
was a perceived threat
to their livestock, they would
catch them in capture cages,
and once caught, they
would usually shoot them.
But why?
Was it because they were causing
a problem to their livestock?
We primarily found that
it was because they
were perceived as vermin.
And that's the same
thing that we, globally,
think of all of our predators.
So I think this is
probably something
that it's not just
our African farmers
but it's farmers worldwide.
That the value of wildlife,
the value of predators,
is really limited.
Farmers, ranchers, the world
really looks our livestock.
But where do wildlife fit in?
What is the value
of conservation?
Our research in our
Cheetah Conservation Fund
really deals with
the cheetah survival.
And we're research-based
conservation program.
So we learn about the
animal, we do conservation,
and we do a lot of education.
The cheetah is an animal
that is very unique.
It lacks genetic diversity.
And genetic diversity
keeps us all healthy.
And the diversity of our
genes is very important.
But the cheetah actually went
through a population bottleneck
about 10,000 to
12,000 years ago,
leaving them very, very,
very genetically the same.
So there's a whole
aspect of biology
that we need to
understand, basic biology.
So we studied the
cheetah in that aspect.
We also then look at how to stop
farmers from catching cheetahs.
Stopping the
human/wildlife conflict,
which has become a model
for predators and people
living together
around the world.
And then, looking
at livelihoods.
Because if you're a
poor, starving farmer,
you really don't
want to have cheetahs
or other predators coming in.
And I always like to ask people,
how many people really would
like to be a poor, starving
farmer in an arid-type area
in Africa?
Anybody?
Usually I find nobody.
And I live as a
farmer in Namibia
because when I moved
there, it was actually
to find out how to live in
harmony with the people.
We have a very
large research area.
And we do a lot of work using
Google Maps and using GIS.
And we study maps everywhere.
So maps are a very
big part of our life.
This is just a little map
with a bunch of dots on it
that says the red
dots were where
we went and rescued cheetahs.
The black dots are when I
went door-to-door and talked
to farmers to find
out everything
there was about their ecosystem.
And that area that's in there
is about the size of California.
This area that's pulled off to
the side is our research area.
And all those other
dots that are over there
are where we use
radio telemetry.
And we now use
satellite collars.
So every little
dot that's there is
where we know a
cheetah has gone.
And then we go out
into those areas
and we understand more
about how it overlaps
with the farms and the farmers
and where the wildlife is.
And understand why the
cheetah went to those dots.
Our biomedical is world-renowned
for the work that we do.
And I just want to put
this in perspective.
We're in the middle of nowhere.
And we've developed
a research center
that is about 25 miles
down a dirt road.
And with that, we have
to make our own power,
our own electricity.
We've got solar panels.
We're trying to go
into biomass power.
We have a generator.
We have to make our
own water, which
means we have to pump it
from nowhere in the ground
because we're in
a very arid area.
So our bore hole's
about 200 meters deep.
But with that, we've developed
a very sophisticated research
center.
I was trained to work out
of the back of my truck
but I thought,
you know, it would
be a lot easier if I could
have a few amenities.
And so I developed a
little veterinary clinic.
And we have a genetics lab.
And this is where we
process our samples.
And we study and learn more
about the cheetah and many
of the other aspects of the
overall health of the cheetah.
Understanding the
cheetah really revolves
around trying to deal
with large landscapes.
And so as kind of Google
mappers-- as I just
think of your mapping
program-- what
does really a large landscape
feel like, look like?
For a cheetah--
cheetahs cover areas
of about 800 square miles.
That's a couple male.
A female my cover a larger
area than that with her cubs.
That's huge.
And they live in
very low density,
over very, very large areas.
So when I talk about what it
looks like to save the cheetah,
I'm not saying a farm.
I'm talking about a continent.
So here's one of the
radio collars that we use.
These are satellite collars.
And they're really cool.
So we program them
and then put them on.
They have a lifetime
of about three years.
But you program them and
then they have a drop off.
And so, as they drop off, you've
collected all this information
via satellite.
Of course, we map it all out.
We know where the cheetahs are.
We primarily like to get data
about every hour on the animal.
And as we start
learning more about it,
we can change that to go maybe
four or five times a day.
And then it uploads--
in the beginning,
if we're putting
a cat out-- daily.
And then, as we start
learning more about the animal
and it settles down, we then
start going to like every week.
So our information
is very extensive.
Each one of these
collars is about $5,500.
But they have a
very long lifespan
and they're very important to
us for the research that we do.
Our ecology is very critical.
Again, kind of a
complicated map here,
but this is what a cheetah's
home range would look like,
over here.
And each one of
these little squares
right here is
about 10,000 acres.
So again, in looking at
what that looks like,
that's about 20 farms.
And that's a typical
home range for a cheetah.
They live in low densities.
There is overlap and
they have avoidance
that goes on through
scat and scent marking.
And so we actually
study the scent
marking by putting
up camera traps.
And these are different areas
where we put these traps.
This is about a 300
square mile area.
And we find about 12 cheetahs
that live in those areas.
And we conduct this
study using camera traps.
And Matti Nghikembua
is our chief ecologist
up at the top having one
of our camera traps there.
And it's allowed us
to understand more
about the distribution and
the density of cheetahs.
We see about four
to five cheetahs
per 1,000 square kilometers.
Again in what their
home range looks like,
male cheetahs live
together their whole life.
Male cheetahs form what
are called coalitions.
They're brothers,
they love each other,
and then they will form a
territory, or a home range,
which is about 400 square
miles as they get smaller.
And then with that, females
cover multiple male home
ranges.
This is different,
like, then any
of the other large
carnivores, or cats.
Because usually it's the males
covering multiple females.
Well, cheetahs are a
little bit different.
Cheetahs have what's
called mate choice.
So they'll find which
male groups that they want
to go mate with.
They also have a
matriarchal society.
So within the
female's home range,
her daughters would stay, she
be in where her sisters are.
In their huge-- and
yet, they do overlap,
but there's a lot
of sociability that
goes on in these very
large home ranges.
The other thing
that we do is-- when
we were able to collect
so many cheetahs
but fortunately we
stopped the farmers
from catching so many-- we still
want to know more about how
cheetahs are living out there.
So we've employed scat
dogs-- or detection dogs.
So all four of these people and
dogs up here are ecologists.
Stephanie is one of our handlers
and trainers of the dogs.
And all three of those
dogs are trained to go
find cheetah scat.
You say, "go find"
and the dog goes off
with a collar on
it that also maps
where it's going, that we
can download and figure out
how far it takes for the
cheetah to go tracking.
And they have quite a
good sense of scent.
And they find the scat, they
sit, and then we come over
and we can collect the scat.
And then we can take it
into our genetics lab.
And we have a very
lovely genetics lab.
We are one of the few
places in Africa--
outside of a couple of
the major cities-- that
actually has a genetics lab.
And our gene sequencer
was donated to us
by Life Science Technologies,
which is also a San Francisco
Bay company.
And we're very proud
to have our sequencer.
And these are two
of our geneticists--
Fabiano just finished his
Ph.D. A few months ago
and Anne is our chief geneticist
that runs our laboratory.
We bring in a lot of Namibian
and international students,
a lot from throughout
Africa that
want to come in and
learn about genetics.
But our Namibian
students as well
are trying to learn much more.
Because we really do need
to train our next generation
of Africans into being very
good scientists as well.
And that's something
that we haven't
done a lot with for the years.
But as we take the scat in
and overlap it with our camera
traps, we can understand
a little bit more
about those
individual cheetahs--
understand their
genealogy, their lineages
through the scat.
And this picture here
shows the differences.
So this picture is three.
And there's another
different cheetah up there.
And this is one of the master's
projects-- one of our master's
students from Namibia
who's actually
looking at identifying
and comparing
the different pictures
with that of our scat
that we're collecting.
And it's a very important
part of understanding
the overall ranges
of the cheetahs.
We use dogs in another way, too.
So we try to find the best
use of many of our friends.
But since Africa is full
of ranchers or farmers--
livestock farmers is
what we call them--
they all have livestock.
And if the livestock
gets caught by predators
then the predators are killed.
So about 15 years ago, we
brought in a breeding group
of Anatolian Shepherd
and Kangal dogs, which
is a very large breed of dog.
And we now breed the dogs and
we donate them to the farmers.
The puppies are
actually placed when
they are about 10 weeks of age.
And we then follow the puppies--
working with the farmers--
to train the farmers in
how the dogs are working.
The dogs have been us for about
5,000 years through Turkey.
And they're an
amazing breed of dog.
They bark loudly.
They act as a guardian
and not a herder.
And they protect the flocks,
primarily through actually just
being there.
And the predators
don't want to get hurt.
They don't want to come in.
And listening to
this large dog bark,
the predators know that
there's something there
that's actually protecting them.
And it was exciting,
on Sunday, we just
had a litter of 10 puppies born.
So it was a fun day for
my staff over in Namibia.
It was my favorite dog
so I'm sorry to have
missed her birthing.
But when I get back
in about a month,
the puppies will be
still another month
to go before we actually
will be placing them.
So we've placed nearly
500 of the dogs.
And as we place
them, they don't get
to just get played
with by the kids.
But this often
helps the kids that
then can go off to schools.
Because throughout
Africa, most of the time,
the children are
the ones that are
herding the family's livestock.
And again, this is one
of my next questions,
if you were that age or
your children are that age,
would you want them out
protecting your livestock?
And what happens when
the leopard comes?
And most of the kids say,
do you want to be out there?
And the kids go, no.
Where would you go?
We'd run back home.
So then, what would
happen to your livestock?
The leopard would probably
eat it-- or the cheetah.
So by having the dogs
out there, the dogs
grow up and become guardians,
the kids can go to school,
the livestock's not killed,
and the system then can work.
So those are the kinds
of things that we
work on training
in programs that we
call Future Farmers of Africa.
Africa's also a place where
we all eat lots of meat,
because meat's about the
only thing there is to eat.
Now when you live in
an arid environment
and there's not very much water,
and most of the rural people
carry their water miles on their
donkeys or on their own backs
to try to get their
water to their villages.
And therefore, you can't
really grow anything.
And that's why people
eat so much meat.
And that's why we have
so much goat and cattle.
And that's why our
landscape is overgrazed.
With that, then, we started
looking at the health of people
and thought, well,
you know, maybe
if they learned that they
had a couple of their goats,
and maybe with those goats they
could learn how to make cheese,
and they could figure out how
to go about doing this even
without electricity, that
perhaps it could help them
and their children
have a better health.
So we set up the
Dancing Goat Creamery.
And the concept with
the dancing goat
is the fact that the goats can
dance because they're protected
by livestock guarding dogs
which are saving cheetahs.
So there is a method to some
of the madness that I have.
These are my staff-- Chapa
helps manage our small stock,
Sharine in the middle is
our main cheese maker,
Chapa has gone through
University of Namibia
as an agriculture major.
Sharine is basically illiterate.
And yet is the best cheese maker
I think there is in the world.
Hanlie helps me in all
of our cooking aspects
and manages the dairy.
She's also a pastry chef.
It's very good.
Big picture.
So I want to talk about
this big landscape
and what it's going to take to
actually have large landscape.
Our backyard, which is on the
other side of the Waterberg
National Park-- which
is this big mountain
up there-- which is a wildlife
park owned by the government.
And our land borders it.
We have about 100,000
acres of land.
We got a very
large piece of land
that we manage as part of
the Waterberg Conservancy.
And it's a buffer to
the wildlife park.
Around us, then, is an area
called the Greater Waterberg
Landscape.
We work with are our neighbors
in managing our wildlife
and natural resources in an
integrated system where we have
enough grazing
land, good wildlife,
our livestock is protected.
And then with that, predators
can play a role in the system.
We also not only have
cheetahs in this area,
we also have wild dogs, which
are one of the most endangered.
Of all the canids, they're one
of the most endangered predator
there is in the world.
So two iconic animals
living in this landscape.
Within this whole
community is also
a group of people which
are called the Herero.
The Herero speaking
people from Namibia--
we've got about 12
different tribal people--
but they have a very
interesting culture.
The women wear these
amazing 25-yard dress,
colonially-looking.
And the weather is
about 120 degrees.
So it's very interesting
that they wear them.
But they are very much
a part of their culture.
The culture is that of
the being a cattle farmer.
And yet, there's no wildlife
in this whole big circle here.
So what our task
has been with that
of the Ministry of Environment
and Tourism and the UNDP--
the United Nations
Development Program--
is to help change this area
over into a landscape that's
going to bring in wildlife.
Change, we hope, the
lifestyles and the livelihoods
from just a strictly
livestock farming community.
And actually have a
mixed wildlife/livestock
going into, for them,
some ecotourism.
And allow an area for animals
like cheetahs and wild dogs.
So a habitat is very,
very important as is prey.
So you cannot have a cheetah or
other predators without having
prey.
And without having
enough grazing land,
you can't have prey.
And if people are hungry,
they will eat all that prey ,
keep the grass for their cattle.
And that's why this balance
of this conservancy-type
initiative, which Namibia is
very famous for, is important.
But a lot of our habitat
is very overgrazed.
And what happened
with overgrazing--
that means the
cattle, and the goats,
and sheep have taken
down all the grasses,
especially when
we have a drought
and there's not very much rain.
And then what's happened is
thorn bushes have taken over.
So our wildlife is
actually changed.
We end up seeing it move.
And it goes into areas
where there's more water
and where there are grasslands.
We have an area
on our land which
is called the Little Serengeti.
And we're starting to see huge
numbers of wildlife species
starting to come back because
of the kind of management
that we've been dealing
with within our conservancy.
But this habitat has
caused a major problem.
And throughout an area, again,
about the size of California,
right in here, that area
used to be an open grassland.
And it's now thickly thorn
bush called bush encroachment.
And our thorns are
horrible and long.
And just imagine
running through this
or even walking through it.
You can hardly penetrate it.
And the bushes have taken over.
They've got very,
very deep roots
that are drinking, each plant.
About 65 liters
of water per day.
So it's a form of
desertification.
And with that, no grass grows.
So we've taken an
area about now--
it's roughly about 26
million hectares of very,
very thick thorn bush that
you cannot even get through.
And you can see this cow,
she can't find her calf.
With thickened thorn bush,
farmers kill more cheetahs
because they can't
kill the bush.
And every other
predator has a problem.
We've found it's affected our
economy by over $100 million
per year by the farmers
not being able to farm.
And what we found is
that cheetahs, actually,
are scratching their
eyes and going blind.
And those animals that
are the ones, that 3% that
might be out catching livestock.
So we've actually
took on a big problem
is to figure out how
to go about dealing
with this bush
encroachment issue.
So we started a habitat
restoration program,
now it's been
about 12 years ago.
I think it was
maybe six years ago
we won the Tech Award
for the environment,
here, in your area.
And it was quite an honor
to be recognized here
in this part of the
world for the work
that we're doing over in Africa.
But we are selectively
harvesting our bush.
We're part of a Forest
Stewardship Council
certification process.
Can I ask how many of you
might know what FSC is?
Forest Stewardship
Council certification.
Hands, no hands, I see one hand.
It is the highest form
of forest protection.
And if we all knew
what FSC was, we
could not only with
every wood product
that we were dealing
with as consumers,
we could be helping a lot of
different wildlife species.
including animals like
elephants and orangutans.
But for us, we're
thinning the habitat
so that we can have
more grasslands.
We're putting a lot
of people to work.
And from that, we made
a little fuel log.
And our little fuel
log's coming around.
It's an ecolog, burns
with very hot heat
with a very low emission.
But out of that, we're now
looking at using biomass.
Again, we've got an area
the size of California.
We get about 10 tons
per hectare harvest
that we could go into
biomass electricity.
Much of this biomass is being
exasperated as well by the CO2
emissions that are going on.
Because they are
affecting and allowing
the trees to actually grow more,
the bushes to grow up more.
So these are what our
fuel logs look like.
And we ask people to think about
eco-partnering and labeling,
and businesses and
business partnering.
And to look at
products that might
be well-labeled or certified.
We started a program
called Wildlife Friendly.
And we did this in cooperation
with several other wildlife
conservation groups that were
working with communities, that
were putting people
into work that
were helping save
endangered species.
So our Certified
Wildlife Friendly
is different than organic
because for animals
like predators,
organic doesn't mean
that you can't use strychnine
and kill all the predators
while you're having
organic lamb.
So those are things
just to think on.
Poaching is a big problem.
And I'd just like to touch
basically on this for a minute.
That the illegal trade is
going from the northern parts
of Africa.
And they're coming in
areas like Botswana,
South Africa, Namibia,
taking small cubs.
Primarily, though,
from Somali land,
which is pretty
lawless up there,
and southeastern
Ethiopia, northern Kenya.
And these cats are going
up into the Middle East.
And for every one cheetah that
might make it there alive,
we probably lose
about five or more.
So the cheetah cubs
are captured and sold
for a very low amount of
money and then usually die.
So they die usually under
about three months of age
from diseases or improper diet.
If they make it to two years
of age, they are very lucky.
Most of them don't.
They die at that time and
then the cubs are gone.
They go back into
the illegal trade,
get more of them from
the wild, and are sold.
so we're spending a lot of
our time up in the Middle East
at this point trying to
work with the Sheikhs.
There are some very,
very good Sheikhs
who are trying to,
actually, help promote
the betterment of the
care of these animals.
Just a couple months
ago, we were up in UAE.
And actually, a lot
of our work also
deals with banking-- bio-banking
of blood, sperm, tissues--
and we trained over 35
of the veterinarians
at several of the different
facilities on how to bank down
the sperm of their
very rare cheetahs.
Many of these
animals-- and these
are at legitimate facilities--
to try to actually help them
more about the overall
health of the animals
and train the veterinarians.
Putting cheetahs into
the wild is, for us,
the most important thing.
And we have put back into
the wild over 600 cheetahs.
We recently are doing a
lot in reintroduction work.
There's places like India
that wants cheetahs again,
Uzbekistan.
And we're working
with those countries
to try to find ways that the
cheetah could possibly go back
out into some of
these other ranges.
We're keeping them living free
and in the wild in Namibia
working in cooperation
with other cheetah programs
throughout the cheetah's ranges.
From Cheetah
Conservation Botswana
to Cheetah Conservation
in Kenya or ACT.
But getting cheetahs in the
wild and keeping them there
is all about all these
components that I talked about.
This is a special
friend of mine.
And he has passed away
now a couple years ago.
His name was Chewbacca.
And he was with me for 16 years.
He came in as an orphan.
And his mother had
been, unfortunately--
well, he'd been
taken from his mom.
And was almost on death's
door when I got him.
He was one of my best
friends and taught me a lot.
But he also taught people
throughout Namibia,
and throughout Africa,
about what a cheetah is.
And when a farmer
would come and yell
at me about his
problems with cheetahs
and Chewbacca would lick
his hand and purr to him
and look in his eyes,
I won that farmer.
And my job was then
to work with him
to find ways that he could live
in harmony with the cheetah.
I don't know how come I ended
up being a cheetah voice
but I've been doing
this for 40 years.
It is the most amazing
animal that I know.
All animals are very special.
And yet, it to me
tells me the job
that we have to do in
spreading the word.
And I thank all of you
for coming and listening
to these things that we have
to say about the cheetah.
Because it's all about thinking
outside of square boxes.
We welcome people
to visit us at CCF.
We take interns and volunteers.
Any one of you can come.
We're always looking for
more capacity in our clinic,
in our genetics lab, working
with us on Google Maps,
in all the different
aspects that we do work on.
And we get people
from around the world
that do come and work with us.
If you just want
to come and visit,
we've got a very nice guest
house which is three bedroom.
It's called the Babson House
and we welcome guests as well.
But we are an open-to-the-public
research center.
So when you're there
at our Babson House,
you're right in
the heart and soul
of the work that
goes on with us.
So I ask everyone to help.
And all of you can
help us as well.
By just spreading
the word and helping
keep cheetahs
living in the wild.
And support the work.
Please spread the word.
Please help buy the
book that's out here.
And share it with others
because it is a special book.
It's called "A
Future for Cheetahs"
because saving
the cheetah really
means changing the world.
As I mentioned before, you
all have changed the world.
And I know that, today, you
could help me change the world
to save more cheetahs as well.
Thank you.
We're going to bring
in Barb and Rob.
And we've worked together
for 20 years, I bet, huh?
And they have an education
center up in Occidental
where they bring their
cheetahs to schools.
And they have
other cats as well.
Barb's been a teacher
for more than 20 years.
And went into helping
us spread the word
to help save our
wildlife species.
So Themba is going to come in.
And he is four years
old next month.
And he was born in South Africa
at the De Wildt Cheetah Center.
And cheetahs don't breed
very well in captivity.
De Wildt's one of
the only places
in the world that's
actually done so well.
There's only a handful of
breeding centers in the world.
And he was hand-raised.
He's fourth generation-- I
think, third generation--
captive born.
And being hand-raised, he's
been able to be an ambassador
by coming here to
meet all of you today.
And I'll just answer
and so we'll just,
you guys get to meet the
cheetah and ask questions, so--
AUDIENCE: You mentioned thinking
about reintroducing the cheetah
to Uzbekistan, I think you said.
What is their natural or
historical northern limit
or their range?
LAURIE MARKER: They were
found in Uzbekistan.
They were in China.
So they had a very big
range throughout all
of Asia and Africa.
And so they went extinct
around the Uzbekistan/Russian
territories in the '80s.
And so that is one of the
areas that they were living in.
They've got vast grasslands,
also very overgrazed.
They're bringing back
their wildlife population.
And the government's got
quite a commitment to this.
It'll be years to do.
We hope that we can
have enough to put back
when that time comes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for being here today.
Since you're doing
genetic work, the cheetahs
that have been taken into other
parts of the world as pets,
are you able to identify where
they came from originally,
based on your genetic research?
That's number one.
And then number two is, I know
that you were saying that there
was a bottleneck was
it 10,000 years ago?
LAURIE MARKER: Yes, 10 to 12.
AUDIENCE: 10 to 12, yeah.
And they were down to, like,
2,000 or something cheetahs?
LAURIE MARKER: Ooh,
we don't even know.
AUDIENCE: OK, OK.
I don't know but I'm heard
that number somewhere.
LAURIE MARKER: Ask
my PhD students.
AUDIENCE: And so,
how genetically
different are the
ones that are found
in different parts of the world,
different parts of Africa?
Are they genetically
somewhat different or are
they still pretty much the same?
LAURIE MARKER: They're
very pretty much the same.
So the divergence actually
occurs over like 100,000 years.
And these look like they may be
diverged much less than that.
So there is some
division in what
they look-- you know,
you can tell one
from one part of the world
to the other or Africa--
but they are very, very,
very much the same.
And we are trying to help
collect that genetic material.
That's why we've gone
up into the Middle East.
And we're trying to
collect everything
that we can from these animals.
So he's going to
walk back and forth.
What Rob has done is he's
putting his meatballs down.
And he's going to look
at where those are.
Now if you notice those
tear marks that run down
from those eyes,
the cheetah's spots
are different than
all the other spots.
Most everyone sees spots and
they are leopards usually.
The cheetahs' got polka dots.
All leopards have are what
are called rosettas, which
is a black circle with
yellow in the middle.
But those tear marks are
what distinguish the cheetah
from any of the
other spotted cats.
You can hear his
claws on the ground.
Cheetahs are the only big
cat that has nonretractable.
Claws-- or they're called
semi-nonretractable.
And their claws are used like
cleats for traction in running.
And that's one of
adaptations that's
helped them run speeds of
up to 70 miles an hour.
When they run, their shoulder
girdles and hip girdles
are not connected.
And they allows them to
have an amazing extension.
And then they've got a
very flexible backbone.
And their tail is very long.
And their tail is used
as a rudder for balance
to help them not roll
over and spin out
at that speed of
70 miles an hour.
A lot of people think that
running 70 miles an hour
is just what they do.
But they really are
more very acrobatic.
So when they run, they're
going side-to-side,
backwards-to-forwards.
And so their tail
plays an important role
as does the body build.
He's purring right
now, I can hear him.
Cheetahs are the only
big cat that does purr.
And they chirp like birds.
They bubble, hiss, spat, growl.
[MAKING CHEETAH NOISES]
Let me see, who else might
have a question out there?
As I said, he's four.
Cheetahs have a lifespan in
captivity of about 12 to 14.
And in the wild,
it's about 8 to 10.
OK?
AUDIENCE: You see
them with the handler
and you see them sitting next to
you, but they are wild animals.
So you're not supposed
to go, "kitty, kitty."
So how tame are they, really?
LAURIE MARKER: Well, these
guys have been hand-raised.
So he was hand-raised
on a bottle.
The cheetah that I was
with was hand-raised
from the time he
was 10 days old.
And they are an animal
that can be tamed.
And that's why
cheetahs are still
one of the few animals that can
be used in educational purposes
by legitimate facilities.
Now, they're registered.
And so there's only a handful
of facilities in the world that
have cheetahs , number one.
And we've been trying to get
that under control so that they
are registered facilities by
USDA here in the United States.
BARBARA DICELY: By
California Fish and Game,
by the US Department
of Fish and Wildlife.
I have many, many,
many licenses.
LAURIE MARKER: Yes.
And so, and they're
used for education.
So it stops people from
just having them as a pet.
BARBARA DICELY: Here
in California, it
is illegal to own any
wild animal as a pet.
Some of the states,
it is still legal.
The laws are
changing dramatically
just so people don't
have a tiger as a pet.
But in California you can't.
So these are strictly
educational outreach
ambassadors.
They are not our pets.
LAURIE MARKER: OK, I've
got three questions.
Here is one.
Right here is two.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering with
the limited genetic cheetahs
have, have you tried
transferring cheetahs
from one of the isolated
islands of population
to the others to sort of
increase the diversity?
LAURIE MARKER: Well, we
have not done that yet
because there's a lot
of international laws
that would prohibit that.
Because the
governments, you know,
like in Iran, their
cheetah is special
and they don't want to
mix it with anything,
even though it might save
them in the long run.
But we're hoping that
intervention through habitat,
education, policies,
and politics
will actually help us try
to grow the populations.
The work that we've done
in 25 years in Namibia
has set a stage and a model
for cheetah conservation
throughout Africa.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
It's very inspiring.
And I wonder how do you plan
to scale up your solution?
And what are the major
bottlenecks that you see?
Thank you.
LAURIE MARKER: I
love your question.
Scaling up is what
my life is all about.
When I first said I needed
to go save the world,
people wondered what
I was talking about.
So our programs around like
Future Farmers of Africa--
so we're trying to partner
with other organizations that
are involved, like
places like CARE
and other humanitarian
organizations who are not
putting wildlife and grazing
lands into the landscape.
Promoting programs
like our conservancies
are very important.
Organizations like
World Wildlife Fund
are very committed to those
kinds of big picture thinking.
So as a small organization,
what we're trying to do
is to get enough funds
to actually scale up.
From our bush
harvesting program,
we actually are looking for
funding to actually scale it up
into biomass power.
We're trying to get power
on our land to start with.
And then show
Namibia that we can
power it through
our bush harvest.
And then, other
places in Africa are
looking at the same
kinds of issues
in wanting to have something
to do with their habitat.
Habitat restoration
is going to be key.
And then looking at
livelihood development.
Getting people out of
that cycle of being
poor, starving farmers.
I'd love you to help.
BARBARA DICELY: You know, the
children as me all the time,
you know, how can we,
living in America,
really help cheetahs
living in Africa?
And as with most things,
it boils down to money.
And if you have, you know-- any
kind of donation you can make,
Laurie puts to amazing use.
It goes directly to saving
cheetahs in the wild.
AUDIENCE: So I know a
lot from watching TV
about how and why dogs
fit into human families.
I don't really
understand the social--
how does a hand-raised cheetah
see the people around it?
Like what does that
social structure look
like in the cheetah world?
Do you know what I mean?
LAURIE MARKER: Well,
like, right here?
AUDIENCE: Or just in general.
What is their social
interaction with other cheetahs
and how do they translate
that to human [INAUDIBLE]?
LAURIE MARKER: Is
this like an orphaned
cheetah like at our place?
AUDIENCE: No, cheetahs
in general, right?
I mean, I think dog
socialize well with people
because they socialize
well with their kind.
LAURIE MARKER: Cheetahs
are very much more
social than what we would think.
And that sociability
in the wild is the fact
that females are covering
large areas with their cubs.
And so they start
with a small area
and grow out and out and
out, covering a lot of areas.
They go to these marking
trees, these play trees,
they know the scents and
smells of the other animals.
So the female's a
very important teacher
in how to live out in the wild.
Males will kind of do avoidance
through, again, scat and scent.
They might use the same
play tree or marking area.
BARBARA DICELY:
He says you never
know where those meatballs
are going to show up.
LAURIE MARKER: Male cheetahs
live, as I said, in coalitions.
And a female's got her cubs
for about nearly two years--
18 to 22 months.
Then the cubs stay together
until they separate,
males separate from the females
and the females have litters.
So it's a very
interesting social life.
AUDIENCE: So these guys
run 50, 60 miles an hour.
Question, just very practical.
When you want to
take him for a run,
do you take him on
the 101, the I5?
How does that work?
BARBARA DICELY: We
have 22 acres of land.
And what we use is
a lure system that
was designed for horse
and Greyhound dogs.
So basically, at
least twice a week, we
do run our cheetahs
to the lure so they
do get lots of exercise.
Their exercising that big
heart, those lungs, the muscles
that they really
need to be healthy.
LAURIE MARKER: Exercise is
very, very important for them.
Yes?
OK.
AUDIENCE: A few
years ago, I went
with my wife to
Africa, Tanzania,
actually, just looking
at all the wildlife.
And it was amazing.
I was there mostly for
the cheetahs, actually,
and I was impressed that
they seemed kind of lazy.
I kept wanting to see
them running after stuff.
Several times we
saw them hunting.
But they'd sort of
gallop-- like trotting--
and they'd just give up.
Do they not actually do the
full out sprints very often?
Maybe we just saw them
when they weren't hungry.
LAURIE MARKER: Maybe.
But they will only
exert themselves
when they know they
have a good chance.
So if they're trotting
after it, they're
kind of assessing the situation.
Oftentimes, they
trot, they stalk.
A hunt could take several hours.
So yeah.
And then, when they do,
it's a burst of speed
that you can hardly
even catch it.
It's like, wow, I
just was looking
at him laying down here
and look at that dust.
How did I miss that?
So it is.
It's amazing.
But like all cats, they
are energy storers.
So they will sleep and
then hunt as they need.
Cheetahs, actually,
will hunt more regularly
than all the other cats.
They like fresh food so they're
hunting on a regular basis.
Female with classes, she's
on the move all the time.
Female cheetahs are the best.
Male cheetahs are the best.
Uh-oh, I think I'm
conflicted here.
AUDIENCE: In your
place, do you have
problems with the
lions and the hyenas?
LAURIE MARKER: Where
we are, because we're
on rural farmland-- and that's
why the cheetah is taken on
into this area is that farmers
have killed all the lions
and hyenas.
We have leopards.
We have baboons.
Both of those are one of the
key problems for the cheetah.
But we've been studying
how the cheetah overlaps
with the leopard as well.
And we ended up living with
baboons these days, too.
So it's rather interesting
how the cycles work.
AUDIENCE: How much
do the cheetahs eat?
LAURIE MARKER:
Well, in captivity,
let us say that they might
eat four or five pounds a day,
an animal this size.
In the wild, then,
it would be they
would eat as much as they
could as quickly as they could.
So it might be eight to
10 kgs, which is maybe 16,
20 pounds just fast.
And then they're
gorged and they might
eat-- if they get to
eat that big of a diet,
they might not eat
for a couple days.
A female, if she's feeding
her cubs, depending
on the size of those cubs,
she is hunting and watching.
Her cubs are eating
fast and she's
going to get some morsels in it.
Unlike lions-- lions
will actually eat first
and the cubs eat last-- a
female cheetah will make a kill
and make sure her
cubs eat first.
So it's a lot of food that they
do consume on a regular basis.
Lean meat.
So of course, the antelope
that they're eating
is also very lean.
AUDIENCE: You just
said that there's
a difference on
how much they eat
in captivity versus the wild.
Does that hurt their
chances of reintroduction
if they're not used
to gorging themselves
when the food is available as
opposed to regular feedings?
LAURIE MARKER: No,
because you have
to keep them on a regular diet.
If you go to a reintroduction,
if they were orphaned animals,
you would start putting
them on carcasses.
So they start learning
how to eat carcasses.
And then they fill
up and go skinny.
It's fun.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
about the Uzbekistan cheetahs.
Where those more genetically
similar to the Iranian cheetahs
or to the African cheetahs
or what are the issues there?
LAURIE MARKER: Well, we don't
know because they're extinct.
We are trying to
find out much more
about some of these
extinct populations
by collecting, like,
samples from the museums.
So they are all so
similar that it's
hard to actually see that much
differentiation with them.
But it would be an animal
that would probably
be much more similar to
that the Iranian cheetah,
the Asian cheetah.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
there are about 10,000
in the wild right now.
I'm wondering what a healthy and
sustainable population would be
or if you have a target
number in mind for that?
LAURIE MARKER: I
kind of like 100,000.
That's not that
many, necessarily,
throughout the continent.
Then if you kind of look
at-- I do a lot of math
and I do a lot of modeling.
You'd have to then look at, if
you need-- and I know so much.
So I'm always figuring
out how much land
they'd need, how
much prey they'd
need, how much
grasslands they'd need,
how many cattle are out there,
how many people are out there.
How do we actually switch that
back into these grasslands
where we've got
wildlife and prey?
The people are actually
getting a different livelihood
than being poor,
starving farmers.
And all the sudden, the people
are doing something different.
And yet the wildlife
is still maintaining
these grassland systems.
Where you then have elephants
and rhinos in the land.
You know, we're looking at
this kind of big support
system for a big continent.
And the wildlife are
a support system,
it's part of biodiversity.
I'd be real happy if we
could double the population
in the next five
years or 10 years.
We've doubled the population
in Namibia in 20 years
and we're kind of
stabilizing it.
But with that, we now
need to, I guess--
and we are-- working
with the other countries
throughout the
cheetah's range in order
to help stabilize those
and grow those populations.
But it's all about people.
And so I just keep
trying to figure out
ways of helping people.
And wanting them all
to love the cheetah.
I mean, wasn't he beautiful?
I know it's not--
I bet you haven't
had a cheetah at Google before.
And on Earth Day.
It's a celebration of
Earth Day, 44 years.
And think you.
You all can do an awful
lot to just spread the word
and get more people
involved in many ways.
And I'm always happy to
answer more questions.
And welcome all of you
to come down and visit.
Oh, I could, I'd be happy
to sign books as well.
Buy books, buy books.
You can also adopt cheetahs
online, or adopt a dog,
at our website.
We've got a really nice
website so please go to it.
Cheetah.org.
If you have kids in
school here and you
want to have the
Dicelys come and bring
one of their educational
programs, they're just amazing.
And they help support
many of us who
have cat conservation
programs worldwide.
But I live in an area
where-- Namibia's got
like 2.2 million people.
And that's not very many
in a very large country.
However, that's why-- we got
lots of thorn bushes-- getting
to know people when I
come over here from Africa
is really nice.
And I hope that you'll all
become part of our family
and let us know who
you are and learn ways
that you can
actually get involved
in making the world different
and better with cheetahs.
So, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]